Shana's in Minnesota
my son is college senior will spend his
last semester studying abroad my
question pertains to using a debit card
in another country his professor
recently told the class may be a good
idea to apply for a credit card before
the trip he suggested that sometimes
places do not accept a u.s. debit card
but would accept a credit card is this
true my son does not want to take on the
burden of a credit card but worried his
professors advice may be true what do
you recommend I recommend you don't
listen to college professors advice on
personal finance ever for anything I
don't know I've traveled all over Europe
all over Africa all over all over and I
have never had any trouble with a debit
card that was substantial now I always
carry some currency for the country that
I'm in I like to have cash I'm a redneck
I want to have a couple thousand dollars
a couple hundred dollars cash whatever
it is in my pocket at all times whatever
wherever I am and so if I do run into
something I can do that but I would say
that 99% of his transactions will be
just fine with a debit card anywhere
they take a credit card I've never had a
problem and I've stayed in some of the
finest places in wherever Harrison
London and Scotland and yeah Russia
wherever we've been all over the dadgum
place Israel wherever and I just have
not had any trouble with my debit card
so that's a personal experience so I
don't know where this professor gets his
insights but you know it's just like the
u.s. there's a few places you run into
things you know that a lot of rental car
companies in the u.s. don't take a debit
card right so you why so what do you do
you work with dollar rent-a-car because
they love Dave Ramsey listeners and
they've redesigned their whole system to
make sure that they love Dave Ramsey
listeners and they take a debit card and
consequently they're getting a bunch of
business to by the way a ton of business
and so and you can go to dollar you know
dollar
a car car rental I'm a dollar car rental
comm and sign up for their Express and
get you know just walk straight out to
the curb and you can do all that with a
debit card with them so you just have to
kind of use your noodle kind of like you
do in the u.s. you're gonna run into
places that that aren't as a debit card
friendly but I'm just not credit card
friendly so I can't do it we were eating
sharing I were eating this wonderful oh
it's so nice
ah we have breakfast in this tiny little
town just outside of Aspen and I got
ready to pay and the lady just smiled
she said you know it'll take plastic
that's so awesome
that is amazing thank God I got a little
cash in the pocket as we just had this
wonderful breakfast at this place and it
was just it was so refreshing so
refreshing cash-only place won't take
your check won't take a debit card
don't take American distress but they
will take green presidents faces I just
love those people I just I'll go back to
heat there can you tell the food was
great but that has made me grin that has
made me happy so you're gonna find
that's true when he's traveling abroad
as well so